people who want the best for you want
you to be your best you going off and
trying to take your shot make somebody
else insecure rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's evan i believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message
surround yourself with great people over
to you oprah winfrey also if you want to
know what oprah and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days i will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I have paid
attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you real work
is to figure out where your power base
is people don't always like you
and they're not always happy for you and
if you surround yourself with people who
are not accustom to your success they
become fearful they become scared
because you are reflecting back
something to them that they don't
recognize now they're not going to say
you know I'm very fearful because you're
reflecting back to me something I don't
recognize they're going to say you know
what they're gonna say they don't say
who she thinks she is
who's she thinks she is that only
happens when you are around people who
do not mean and want and aspire to the
best for you people who want the best
for you want you to be your best so my
greatest advice to you is to surround
yourself with people who are going to
fill your cup until your cup runneth
over so when people say you're so full
of yourself you can say yeah yes I'm
full I'm so full my cup runneth over and
to know that once your cup runneth over
you cannot spend your life with your
gallon-sized offerings offering them to
pint-sized people
[Music]
you have got to surround yourself with
gallon-sized people who can hang in the
same company with you so that you're not
offering your gallons to those little
pipes out there who can't hold it anyway
not everyone is going to be happy for
your success that sucks but it's true a
lot of people around you will not be
happy when you go off and accomplish
success why a lot of times is one
because people are too afraid to go off
and take their shot or they have tried
once taking their shot it didn't work
out and they're too afraid to go and do
it again and so these people the ones
who are too afraid the ones who can't go
out and take their shot instead of going
off and doing their thing they focus
their efforts on tearing other people
down you going off and trying to take
your shot make somebody else insecure
and so instead of them acknowledging
that and then going off to do their
thing they want to pull you down and so
not everyone will be happy for your
success that sucks
but you playing small to live up to
their tiny expectations of you is not
going to be the answer that will make
you happy in the long run people who
feel your ears with negativity need to
be cut out you do not need their
approval you do not need their
acceptance and the difference between
you going off and accomplishing your
goals or staying exactly where you are
right now will be your ability to tune
out the negativity and stay focused on
your objective okay so how do you do it
how do you eliminate the negativity how
do you get more positivity in your head
how do you stay focused on your goals
when everybody around you or at least a
lot of people around you are saying you
can't do it I'm gonna give you three
tips on what to do next
number one is cut the cancer you need to
eliminate the people in your life we're
filling your head with negativity or at
least limit the exposure some of these
people might be friends that you grew up
with you may have known them for decades
years years years years of relationship
but if they are filling your head with
negativity you do not need these people
in your life anymore a lot of times the
people that we stick with in our lives
are just out of convenience their
friendships because we've had them for
years but you've grown as a person they
maybe haven't
so much and so you staying friends with
them doesn't serve either of you very
well cut the negative people out of your
life now and maybe your family maybe
your mom and maybe your uncle Joe
you know maybe hard to completely cut
them out of your life okay that's fine I
get it
it may make sense you the cut them out
completely but if not limit your
exposure don't hang around them as much
or watch the topics that you talk about
if you know that talking about your
dreams your ambitions your goals your
company is gonna set them off into a
tirade of negativity then they'll bring
it up and any time they try to bring up
your career switch topics say you don't
want to talk about it you're gonna move
on to something else don't take the bait
don't dive deep into that conversation
because you know it's only gonna lead to
negativity you don't get to pick your
family but you do get to pick your
friends so if it's your family then
limit the exposure watch out the topics
that you cover and if it's your friends
if they are filling your head with
negativity you need to cut the cancer
out of your life number two is be the
tree if there is ever something negative
in your life that you cannot eliminate
you cannot completely avoid you have no
option you have to live with it I then
like to use that as fuel for positivity
and so I have an expression called be
the tree and what I see is entrepreneurs
we are trees and what does a tree do a
tree in the environment is sucking up
poison carbon dioxide is poison right a
breeze in the carbon dioxide poison it
eats it grows from it into a powerful
tree and then what does it do it spits
out positivity it spits out oxygen it
breathes in the poison eats it grows
from it and then spits out oxygen
positivity that is what we do as
entrepreneurs and so for those negative
people that you can't completely
eliminate from your life change your
mindset that you will be the tree that
you will eat their negativity you will
become a better person because of it and
you will spread oxygen positivity for
everybody around you be the tree and
number three is fill the void with
positivity so if you've taken the steps
to eliminate some of the negativity now
you've got a void now you've got extra
time that needs to be spent fill it with
positivity it's what I try to do with my
youtube channel I want to surround
myself with positivity I want to
surround myself with people
you're on my wall with the videos that I
make for you guys I want to surround
myself with people who believe in a
better world and greater things and I do
it through my content but whatever the
thing is that makes you feel bold
positive unstoppable courageous plan
that into your calendar filled that void
you're sucking out the negativity now
you need to inject the positivity so
whoever's messages you need to hear if
it's mine if it's Oprah it would Steve
Jobs if it's Martha Stewart if it's
whoever whoever the person is make that
a part of your regular schedule so you
are injecting positivity that fills you
up that makes you feel courageous so
that you can go off and do the crazy
thing that you want to do now I've got a
really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
is the single greatest source of
positivity that you want more of in your
life let me know put it down in the
comments below
you've gotta break out of that pattern
you got a knotless in him and make it
fun and however way you want listen
otherwise you're stuck if you want to
help your mom sometimes the best way to
help your mom is to get out and then
come back and get her out get it so
honestly well honestly and I respect
that right now it's when you're 14 it
feels like it's your life forever you
understand as much positive patient I
get it but you understand there's no
alternative there's only two choices
here you stay under that roof and eat it
for four more years two more years to 40
years or you bounce now
it's not common in the UK but people do
it or you don't
life's about a very simple option
these are doing you know if you're gonna
you need to put your your pods in and
listen to positivity 24/7 you understand
when your surroundings are your insides
got to be positive in fact even 14 four
more years so what do you say and to
stay which is more likely just fine
you gotta put positivity in your ears do
you understand I promise you you have no
other alternatives otherwise you just
dwell and you go down to spiral that you
don't want to go down you understand
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people with passion and not one drop of
my self-worth depends on Europe it's
suppose to mean if you want more Oprah
check out the in stress so we did on her
on how to work on yourself the link is
right there next to me I think you're
gonna enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there sure real work is to
figure out where your power base is